slow down the macro and speed up the
micro people get confused on this
because you talk a lot about patients
too and they think that means well I
should just go slow for some reason
people have decided to turn the word
patience into passiveness more than the
two words exist when I say be patient I
don't mean lay on your couch and watch
TV I mean stand up people don't
understand this put on the macro speed
up the micro what does that mean expand
that for a second this is my calendar
like it's constant I did 15 meetings
before 1 pm today like everyone needs to
really really really really really speed
up their day-to-day but slow their skis
on their big goals enjoy the process
don't rush to get the trophy yeah